all right harvey
harvey harvey where'd you grow up where
are you from originally
l.a grew up in l.a and tell me about
your childhood you had mom and dad oh
yeah mom and dad a couple of brothers
pretty much middle class
how would you describe your childhood
i was
good and happy and constructive
pretty much
uh except when when i turned about 15 16
my my dad got a brain cancer i'm sorry
and i died slow it was from a service
related uh
he taught radar in the army air corps
world war ii the pilots and navigators
um
so he got exposed a lot of microwaves in
it so you lost your father yeah he died
at the va on wadsworth
early 70s
where did your life go important where
did your life go after that
uh well you know
things things warning i was i was going
to school
i pretty much stayed in school i stayed
out of the war
um how old are you
i'm uh 72
yeah you had jobs
in your life yeah
family trade is a locksmithing
so i did that
um different types of construction
did you get married have kids i i got
married never had any kids
but uh
so how did you end up living on the
streets here in santa monica well uh
yeah the
the first time i i split from home when
my dad got sick for
a little while a few weeks
uh when i was about
uh i kind of had that kind of lifestyle
for a while in the 60s hitching around
and whatnot
uh and that
i had a tree nursery and i was married
got divorced and this and that
i did environmental studies
at school
i went to berkeley 68 through 70
after a year in santa barbara and then
santa cruz
you graduate yeah
you got a degree pardon you got a degree
yeah but
i only got it like 10 years ago and i
wanted to get a double degree in
environmental studies and political
economics
um and they wouldn't give me
they gave me the environmental studies
but they wouldn't give me the political
i'm still thinking about going back and
kicking that one loose good for you
anyway so you've been living on the
streets here how long uh well
i i i worked on the pipeline up in
alaska and i got busted up my neck and
back
um
and i was after that i was on workers
comp for about a half a year and then i
got
i was i was on for five years
and then
more recently back in uh
in 13 about 10 years ago
i headed outside again
uh i was inside for a couple years
on and off and this and that are using
drugs or alcohol uh
i i use alcohol for pain
i used to get uh
vicodin and norco but they cut me off
about a year ago with all this [ __ ] with
fentanyl
and
i smoked pot i hadn't smoked
uh like
35 years since
since the mid-80s
oh you smoke a lot of pot
i i do
i smelled it when you got in my car yeah
all right
and uh that's what i need need the 50
for
it helps you with the pain yeah it helps
a lot and uh
also to eat
how do you support yourself i i get uh
social security
um
i i've been doing the environmental
stuff for a long time
and i
i know a lot about solar energy
and uh i've been doing policy stuff
mostly at the air district but at the
state and whatnot
to try to get them to do solar energy to
solve air pollution and
use existing laws and existing
technologies
anyway where do you stay at night where
do you sleep uh well
right now i'm over by up
but when i was on the street i'd like to
stay by uh
on the benches when they had benches and
uh
anyway
sometimes
different times different things yeah
what's it like living
on the streets as a 72 year old well
it's it ain't getting easier
and uh i i think that we could do a lot
better in terms of
you know health care and stuff like that
what do you think the solution is
well
i think public public health
you know
it's it's a significant part of our
economy and it's a lot of money
i don't know
seems to be getting worse and worse
every year
yeah
it doesn't seem to be getting much
better i guess we've made some kind of
progress they say there's another
you know 10 20 million uh
people covered and
so that's good
so your marriage ended yeah
yeah how many years did you i was
we were together about four years
married about three
two and a half
what kind of emotions do you go through
emotions yeah do you get depressed or
angry or anxiety both yeah
depression anxiety uh
i i've i've had diagnoses
across the board like what kind of what
kind of site psych diagnosis and i've
got different types of physical ailments
besides my busted up neck and back from
working
and uh
i was on psych meds for a while but i've
spent
about eight ten years since i've been
off to treat what depression
depression anxiety
schizophrenia
yeah yeah it's pretty common nowadays
well i don't know they say they say the
numbers
minor sending is the numbers
a pretty constant three six percent or
something
do you enjoy anything about this
lifestyle this homeless lifestyle uh
uh
that you get appreciation for the little
things
you get you get your uh try to get your
quality of life where you can
how do you
maintain some quality of life
smiling and waving to a little kid
that's nice
if you're not offending the parents
do you have friends
uh
yeah
but
getting fewer and far between
what was the best time of your life
uh
i don't know
maybe back in the old days
you know
the
60s 60s
70s
i don't know
what was the worst time uh
i don't know i don't think i've seen him
yet
i'm
i'm not a real
pollyanna type of thinker
i've been getting more into like the
prince machiavelli
hobbes
the call of the wild do you think things
are good how the wolf's fight pardon
what do you
i think we've reached our ecological
limits
i think we we
we kind of sense it intuitively in half
for a while
do you think we're on a downward slide
yeah i think those climate stuff is very
real
and i'm way off into that
what are you afraid of what do you worry
about
personally or
as a society
well
all things must must end uh the only
thing that's constant is change
and uh
it is what it is
um
[Music]
things are certainly changing
you have any regrets in your life
requests um
i don't know i don't i don't dwell on it
that much
if you had your life to live over again
what would you have done differently
well i might have taken some jobs that
were offered me
um
you know different things
i was offered a job with the
environmental protection agency when it
was just formed in 1970s they took four
students and i was back there
with the living christmas tree in 70 i
met the head of the ruckles house of epa
and they offered me a job with
the in the white house with the
president's
uh
test was it
council on environmental quality i was
going to represent the west
i turned them down
it was kind of a communications
blunder with with my ex she was from
connecticut
and she didn't know out here and stuff
and i said hey i got offered a job
in in washington
uh you know working with the president
on this environmental stuff and she goes
washington she goes we're going to go to
alaska i'd worked in alaska
so let's let's go to the left we're
driving up there we're going through
washington stations hey this is like
really pretty maybe you should have
taken that job on why i said no no no
washington dc not washington
the white house
such as
how do you
think living on the streets like this
has changed you you've been doing it for
a while yeah well
it it influences the way i
look at my environment and judge people
are you an optimist or a pessimist
the whole
so you're a realist
uh well
so we hope
uh
anyway what do you think was the biggest
factor and why you're in this situation
today
um
well i'm not a conventional type of
person
um
[Music]
i've always been way off into the
environment and stuff i was in the
scouts and all this
um recycling and stuff
yourself hope for your future
yeah
but uh
trying trying to you know reassess and
find out what's what's real and
you know
what do you
what are your thoughts of the future of
this country oh that scares the [ __ ] out
of me
you know this thing about
yeah i've been outspoken i go to the air
district i'm an activist you know
and i talk stuff at the air district and
sometimes carb
but uh
i said you know
the republicans are not a party
all these guys are sworn to office they
they swore on the constitution
are one section eight is science
all right the scientific method
you know the same section that lets us
print money and have a militia
um and that and they're not using
science and evaluating our situation
anyway and then the polarization and how
they characterize it and our propensity
for dichotomies
that's what concerns me
yeah
and you know and nukes
and then they said
was the
guy that was in the chair hawkins he
said uh
number one threat to humanity is nukes
number two is climate change unless
climate gets worse the
the probability of nuclear war increases
this guy harari is like added you know
ai and
machine learning and crispr
you know
the rate of change in the hormones do
you think you think we have a tendency
to self-destruct as a species well
not i think life does that's that's life
you know
it's a natural process that's nature
yeah nature seems to
anyway well yeah these questions
yeah they're endless what do you think
is the most important thing you've
learned in your life
uh
to try to recuperate every once in a
while and uh i was a distance runner all
right so um
i've kind of been like that uh in other
ways
is getting old frustrating for somebody
who's an athlete well
yeah but i'm still moving around a
little bit
anyway
all right
harvey thank you so much for sharing
your story
i wish you the best of luck okay thank
you thank you very much
you